breaking here at five o'clock new 9-1-1  calls released in that horrific case of  the las vegas boy found dead in a  freezer thanks for joining us i'm denise  valdez and i'm brian loftis this is a  story we first brought you last month  four-year-old mason dominguez's body was  believed to have been in that freezer  for months his mother's boyfriend at the  time brandon toslin accused in his  murder and today eight news now obtained  some of the 911 tapes described in the  moment mason's sister went to school  with a note of warning from her mother  technically the mom says please help  send police  there are guns in the house we just  wanted to set up the welfare check with  the mom so mom more than likely gave  that to her daughter  toslin is charged with two counts of  kidnapping and one count of open murder  he is due back in court on the 7th of  april